so this is the area where we saw police
for the last three days searching and
you can see we've walked now down onto
the peninsula they've lifted the police
Cordon here evidence of trees that we
saw being cleared we can walk further in
as well
and you can see really just how remote
this location is
as we go through and I can already see
in front of me more very clear evidence
of trees which have been cleared so you
can see here
the fresh cutting
of the stumps
and the reason that the police have been
focusing on this point for the last
three days is because of a tip-off that
was given to the German prosecutor
so they asked the Portuguese authorities
if they relaunch or search the first
search on Portuguese soil for Madeleine
McCann in nearly a decade and what we've
seen is teams from the UK from Germany
from Portugal coming down here
and bringing heavy machinery to clear
this land as you say also
bringing dogs now if I come a bit
further here
we can see an area if you want to go in
front pool that has clearly been
excavated
um have a bit more of a look
um
so holes here
in the ground area
so clearly this is a way that they've
been collecting evidence the reason that
they focused on this area is because
it's believed to have been a haunt
for
the prime suspect that was named in this
case by the Germans and also named as
Person of Interest by the Portuguese
Christian b a convicted sex offender in
prison
in Germany now he's always denied any
involvement in The Disappearance of
Madeleine McCann
but uh
police and prosecutors because of this
tip-off decided this was a place that
they wanted to visit because it's
believed it was a place that he came
often he said it was his paradise
allegedly so these holes
potentially where they've taken soil
away to test
or possibly where they've seen something
that they want to uncover
also you can see here more Earth
which has been moved
and then if we walk back further down
onto the shore
we can have a look
at some of the other things that they've
done so here are the trees again you can
see
that they have cleared
um
and it was interesting because this tree
clearing still seemed to start more on
the second day that's when we saw this
the big heavy machinery
coming in
um
and we saw teams with dogs coming around
this area we were on the other side of
the bank but we could clearly see
they brought in the sniffer dogs
and
they brought them to the other side
we'll just move around because obviously
other media are here as well this is a
case which has caught
the attention of the world really for 16
years it's not just of course the family
who are desperate for answers
many many people want to know what
happened to Madeleine McCann who of
course disappeared from that
apartment in Prior de leash in May
so you can see
this was an area a huge Reservoir here
in front of us
this was an area which had been searched
in 2008 a year after Madeleine McCann
disappeared
by a Portuguese lawyer who hired a
private team
and nothing was found then but because
of this tip-off
German prosecutors asked for the search
to be redone again
now as it stands we don't know if they
found anything of Interest they're
taking away whatever they found we've
seen them moving away with
white bags for the last three days we
don't know what was in those bags there
have been unconfirmed reports that they
were told to look for rags
that certainly has not been confirmed by
any officials understanding that this
information came from a credible
informant
but the important thing to remember is
though the search teams have gone this
investigation is far from over they will
now be spending the next time testing
anything that they've got doing further
research continuing to try to find out
what happened to Madeleine McCann